You must almost certainly have heard about the controversy over the car
company,
folks Vargon and diesel engines and nitrogen oxides.
Now I did want to talk about the controversy,
but the chemistry is really interesting.
So I thought you ought to know about it.
The first thing to say is that this involves diesel engines.
There are two sorts of engines that you can have in cars that petrol engines
and diesel engines, and they use slightly different fuel.
And the main difference between the engines is that in the petrol engine,
there's the spark plug,
which sets fire to the mixture of petrol or
gasoline as you stay in the states and there,
and the flame spreads from the top of the cylinder downwards and pushes the
piston in a diesel engine. There's no spark plug,
but the piston going upwards compresses the mixture of
air and fuel, which gets hot because you're compressing it.
And it spontaneously starts burning.
The advantage of diesel engines is that you can build them very much
bigger for cars, for trains, for even for ships,
but with a petrol engine, there's a limit to the maximum size.
The result of the different way of igniting the setting,
fire to the fuel is that the chemistry takes place
inside slightly differently because the temperatures are different.
And the way the flames spreads in both engines,
you have a mixture of air and fuel air contains
oxygen, which makes the fuel burn.
It also contains nitrogen gas and two,
and under the high temperature conditions,
some of the nitrogen gas just a tiny bit can react with
oxygen.
And it makes a mixture of oxides of nitrogen.
The two called NOx X is a number which is normally either
one or two.
The reason why we worry about NOx is because these
molecules are really quite reactive.
And the reason is that nitrogen has seven electrons and oxygen
atom as eight.
So if you have either an a or an a too,
it will have an, the number of electrons.
It will have one extra electron that is not paired up,
and this makes the molecules much more reactive.
So if you want to preserve the quality of air in the
city or beside the road,
you want to minimize the amount of any wakes coming out of the exhaust pipe.
Diesel engines produce more NOx than petrol
engines. So in diesel engines,
you have to take special precautions or procedure to try and
minimize the amount of NOx,
especially in the latest cars which are designed to meet strict
emission limits. The chemistry that is used is relatively simple.
You have a catalyst which reacts the NOx with
urea.
Urea is a compound of ammonia and SIO,
or it's made from ammonia and CEO. It has two NH,
two groups bound to one C O group urea
is made industrially,
but it is a product that you can find in urine, for example,
and they have been all sorts of jokes about people with diesel cars,
relieving themselves into the engine to make them better, but that's by the by.
But the key point is that you have a reaction between
urea and NOx,
which generates ammonia and nitrogen
and CO2. So in the latest cars,
there is a tank which contains what I believe is a very
concentrated solution of urea.
I don't know the precise details because although I own a folks' wagon diesel,
it's too old to have one of these.
The idea is that a very small amount of this solution is injected into the
exhaust stream. There is a reaction, the NOx is removed.
The scandal has been because the computer that
controls the whole engine has been programmed.
So it only puts the urea in when the engine is being tested for
emissions. And I believe the reason for this is just to save the customers,
having to top up the tank of urea though.
Some articles that I've read,
suggest that it may affect the performance of the engine as well.
So you can't accelerate quite as quickly or whatever it should be said
that the catalytic converters in cars,
whether they're gasoline cars or diesel cars are
really very clever because what is coming out to the exhaust pipe
contains gases like carbon monoxide,
or perhaps even methane, which needs to be burnt, reacted with oxygen.
And there are other things like NOx that need to be
reduced. You need to remove the oxygen.
And therefore the computer that controls the engine,
the so-called energy management system has to
adjust the amount of oxygen going into the engine very
carefully. And in fact,
one of the key components is a oxygen sensor
that sits in the exhaust pipe so that it can work out oxygen levels.
And those of you who are watching in the UK,
who have long memories may remember that there was some cheap petrol
that was sold a few years ago that managed to ruin the
oxygen sensors in a whole series of cars.
I think 10,000 cars who'd been to those particular petrol stations.
The reason that we have cleaner emissions from cars now
is because the engines are computer controlled and we can adjust the
chemical conditions inside them very precisely.
And unfortunately it was realized, I don't know,
by whom in folks' Vargon that they could manipulate these things so
that they could make the engine cleaner sometimes than others.
So this is where we're going to get our CO2 from. It's a rather large cylinder.
So on, on the cylinder, we have a device called a regulator,
which you can see here.
And, uh,
draw this direct line between the folk swag and Hitler. I mean, there,
there was, of course he was behind the wheel to subsidize it.